so I'm going to try to do something a
little bit hard I know that not
everybody knows what a Bitcoin protocol
is and how it works so I'm gonna try to
introduce you to the protocol very
quickly I hope I won't end up confusing
you too much and then I want to get to
more advanced topics and specifically I
want to to highlight how algorithmic
game theory and other related issues are
very important for Bitcoin and why you
should all start to look at at this
problem which is very applied on the one
hand and I think theoretically deep on
the other hand so let's let's get
started with what Bitcoin basically
tries to do
so here's what happens usually when we
send money digitally right if we have a
bunch of people or agents who are
interested in in sending money to each
other there's usually a bank in the
middle and the bank has balances rights
of everybody accounts and when we want
to move money we basically create these
messages saying okay I want to move
money I'm the red guy I want to move
money to the blue guy you send them to
the bank the bank says ok this checks
out I see your signature this is very
much like a check and the balances are
changed in the account and banks of
course can do all sorts of text on your
on your requests so for example if the
red agent now would try to move again
one maybe one dollar to the green guy
that would get thrown out he has no
money in his account and so we we have
to make some consistency checks here
that the bank does for us now bitcoin
really wants to replace this bank with a
peer-to-peer system of nodes these are
now computers that will do all that work
for us so the way to think about it is
that each of them is now going to be a
bank they're all going to hold all the
balances they know everything and
they're going to basically take turn
authorizing these transactions that's
what they're gonna do okay so we're
going to simulate the same experience
for people from the outside and the real
problem that we now face is that where
before we had just a central entity that
could check consistency things are now
more complicated and you can think of
the red agent maybe trying to pull some
tricks on us he's either moving money to
the blue guy or moving it to the green
guy but he so he creates these two
messages and he sends them to different
parts of the network at the same time
trying to confuse us okay so this is the
real challenge and this is very related
to the Byzantine generals problem if you
know it from from distributed systems
and so this is what bitcoin has to solve
and the problem was actually solved in
all cases where we did have identities
of nodes in the system the new part here
is that this has to be an open system
now we want it to be open to any
participant in order to increase
competition in transaction transmission
so we're allowing everybody to enter we
have no way to verify how many
identities we are we have in the system
we have Sybil's we have any any other
form of tech you know people might might
try and and abuse the protocol so the
way that Bitcoin really handles this is
through a data structure called the
blockchain and the way to think about
blocks is they're basically collection
of collections of transactions these
transfers that have been somehow
accepted think of the bank that you know
was previously accepting some
transactions and maybe throwing some out
and every block is just the set of
transactions that a node has accepted
when it was its turn to be the bank
basically when it's when it was its turn
to to verify things so when a node
basically wants to add new transactions
it'll build a new block okay so one one
thing that I maybe should say here these
these things form a chain there's a an
identifier here of the previous blocks
in the chain that's a cryptographic hash
but if you don't know what that is then
just think of it as a as an identifier
of the previous block so these arrows
really go back in time
and they say okay this block is now
extending this history of transactions
and I'm going to include the new
transaction maybe red is Greek giving
money to blue and now that we have this
I mean this represents a history that we
can read from start to finish and
understand where all the money is and
what happened and we can adjust the
balance is just as the bank did it's
centrally before now the the main
problem of course is that when this
block was created when when a node
thought that it's it was its turn to be
the bank some other node in the system
I'm sorry
some other node in the system may have
done the same thing and while this node
could have rejected a certain
transaction like we saw before
maybe they received these messages in a
different order and money going from red
to green was actually approved here
before that transaction so there could
be a conflict in what we think had
happened in the recent batch of
transactions so these are basically two
points of views that that nodes hold and
the real challenge to the protocol is
how to reconcile these how to eventually
come to agree on one point of view and
and then we know where all the money is
and so on so Bitcoin basically uses a
bunch of rules to help settle these
unfortunate events the first rule is to
is to first make the block creation
itself a very hard thing to delay it
kind of artificially by adding the
requirement that you're going to do
you're going to have to do a lot of
computational work and and embed inside
each block the answer to a very hard
puzzle okay so so these blocks also
contains contain solutions that are
dependent on the contents and on the
history so they change from from time to
time and you have to really find a
solution to a hard problem which which
is if you know what it is basically
inverting a a cryptographic hash
function partially so these are now this
now throttles the block creation makes
it really slow so we create a block
every 10 minutes or so
through the entire
core network that means that there are
batches of transactions that are being
processed accepted all together and this
is a very right it's a very long period
of time to wait but the end result is
that we almost never have these sorts of
collisions happening right if two nodes
create blocks it's usually not at the
same time it takes about ten minutes for
one of them to solve this computational
problem this is only an expectation it
has to basically guess inputs to the
problem so we don't know when when the
solution will appear so these conflicts
are very rare the next thing that
Bitcoin tries to do is of course once we
do create one of these blocks we send it
out to everybody in the network very
very quickly so that when the next one
is built it'll be built on top of it and
you know we can we can tell that red has
already given money to blue and we
should reject transactions like this so
if blocks are propagated really fast
that also helps us to avoid these
conflicts and the final rule is perhaps
one of the most important ones states
that if we do end up with two blocks
that have been created almost at the
same time by nodes maybe by accident
this could still happen we have to
somehow again resolve this issue then
what we'll do is we'll have nodes accept
the history of another node only if it
presents a longer chain than what it
currently sees okay so these two chains
we basically have two chains of the same
length so two nodes will not accept the
other ones point of view they keep on
working they keep adding transactions to
this to this to their own version and at
some point in time another block will be
formed either here or here and when the
other part of the network sees this
longer chain of events they will abandon
what they're doing and accept the longer
sequence okay so that's that's basically
the core of the Bitcoin protocol this is
how things are currently done so so now
what we really need to worry about
this form of attack called the double
standard tag double spending where
somebody who really tries to misuse
funds and and pay with the same money
twice so let's suppose I'm the red guy I
have a transaction here somewhere that
was accepted into the Bitcoin system
some blocks may have been built on top
of it and now I want to move the funds
somewhere else
so if you remember the last rule that I
that I just mentioned says that if I
show you a longer chain you're going to
have to write every note that the
network is going to have to abandon this
one and adopt my longer chain and here I
can embed a transaction that basically
moves the money to a different location
all right so this is the bad thing that
might happen if we change our mind about
some transaction happening and we switch
the destination to a different place so
the intuition is that this is very hard
to do okay because in order to create
this long chain of blocks I have to
solve many many computationally hard
puzzles right and I have to do it faster
then the network is building its own
chain here so this is something that
I've kept hidden and at some point I
just release it for everybody to see but
in the meantime this chain keeps growing
by you know nodes in the network that
are solving these puzzles and keep
adding more and more blocks on top so
the basic theorem that stands at the
core of Bitcoin is basically one that
its inventor presented in the first
paper that he wrote about this in 2009
he started the system but in 2008 late
2008 he released the paper that explains
how it works
and he basically has one theorem there
one central theorem that says that if we
have these two assumptions that that
nodes can really send blocks quickly to
each other and that attackers only write
in the attacker whoever's trying to
switch where money is going is is
controlling only 50% or less of the
compute that you write strictly less
than 50% of the computational power then
we
essentially be safe okay this the
probability that block will be replaced
once we see it in the chain decreases
exponentially as the chain slowly grows
okay so basically because the task of
replacing it gets harder and harder and
so what we really have to do in order to
think of a of fans as having been moved
and secured we wait for them to enter
the blockchain we wait for the
blockchain to grow and the amount of
growth really is specified you know
within this theorem how much security do
you want and you you basically gain
exponentially fast right this
irreversibility of transactions so one
of the problems is that when you look at
this assumption it's very hard to know
what to make of it to you right we don't
know how what the attackers that are out
there are doing how much computational
power that they have so this is not
something that we can easily work with
so Bitcoin really replaces this
assumption right we very often think of
something that instead of thinking of
how much power the attacker really has
we try to get the network itself to be
very large and very in the sense of of
having a lot of computational power
invested in solving this these
computational puzzles and and building
blocks so we need to have nodes
incentivized somehow to participate in
the system now this is where incentives
come into play and really every time
that the the protocol somehow gets into
trouble it's because this main theorem
somehow is compromised because of this
assumption or this assumption these are
the places where most attacks on the
protocol come from right so here there's
an underlying assumption that we are
connected we can send quickly right
communication networks are not
interacted with and so on and when we
when we try to attack the protocol one
way is to attack this assumption another
way another line of work has really
worked on this one basically showing
that we can break the incentives of
nodes and there
for we will have large attackers come up
very easily and the protocol will not be
safe okay so these are two avenues for
attack I'm really going to talk a little
bit about both of them right each one of
them yes I'm going to say how to attack
here I'm not going to talk about attacks
here but but there is something some
sense in which this assumption degrades
when you speed up the protocol and I am
going to talk about that given given
enough time so let's talk about the
incentives we need to incentivize a lot
of nodes right to enter the system to
join us and to invest computational
effort in in creating blocks so the best
way is actually to pay them right so
whenever somebody creates a block it has
all these transactions inside of it and
we're going to collect a little bit of
money from each one this is a kind of a
fee for using the system and to that
we're gonna add money that we're
creating out of thin air this is the way
the money is created in Bitcoin and this
is going to go directly to the person or
write to the node who built this block
so here's your reward for building
blocks in the system so basically every
time you solve this very hard
computational problem you get a little
bit of bitcoins and this is why you know
this process has been named mining you
work really really hard and you mind a
little bit of gold or digital gold in in
some sense so I people often refer to
this as mining and to the nodes who work
at it as miners all right so so this
seems really nice
here's by the way the rate of money
printing in the Bitcoin system you may
have heard that the Bitcoin is only
going to have a limited is you're going
to have a limited supply of coins
basically 21 million units of bitcoins
and they can be fractionally you know
they can be broken up to France the
smaller fractions but basically we are
creating them at a very fixed schedule
which is converging we started in 2009
and the rate is having every four years
so it's a little bit hard to see but
this is a straight
line and the slope here is 1/2 and so on
until this converges and so the money
supply is eventually fixed once we get
to this point all of our incentives will
be just from the fees from transactions
and not from minted currency so this is
an overview of how Bitcoin was set up
and of course people really quickly
understood that's you know this thing
that you usually tell us on the internet
that you can make money with your
computer is not a scam anymore it's
really true you can make money with your
computer so they started hooking up a
lot of them to the network
right these are incentives at work right
very quickly people understood that the
problem that we're trying to solve with
Bitcoin the hashing cryptographic hashes
running them many many many times is
basically something that you can do with
custom hardware and the state of Bitcoin
mining today is that it's done in these
huge warehouses where people really pour
millions of dollars into specialized
hardware that does it much much faster
than regular computers but there are
also solutions if you want to be a miner
at home you can actually buy on Amazon
there's a there's a new computer that's
just been sold by a company called 21
Bitcoin right 21 million Bitcoin that's
what the name refers to and you can buy
for maybe $400 something that hashes or
does this computation a thousand times
faster than a regular PC yeah
so the investments in these are are I
think every these typical mines are tens
of millions of dollars worth of hardware
but in some of the operating costs are
really more about the electricity and
efficiency of just doing the the
computation yes and they actually do get
those technical backs okay so some of
them have been very profitable in the
past so as a result what you'd expect is
is really happening the the the
computational power invested in in
Bitcoin is growing very fast it's grown
really exponentially as we were slowly
transitioning to to stronger hardware
that does this and and what we really
wanted is the network to be more secure
so in some sense we've done it right
there's a lot of computation going on
all of it is somehow supporting the
security of Bitcoin and anybody who
wants to attack and do a double spend
attack has to match the investments
basically in hardware an electricity
that's going to the Bitcoin network
anyway all right so this is why many
people tell you that bitcoin is very
wasteful because it does all these
computations and really the result is is
thrown out nobody really cares about
what it is but but that's the state of
things yeah so that's that's a good
question so first of all I think the
cost depends on a lot of things the
value of the currency for example if
we're printing a certain amount of
bitcoins per per day then of course when
the value of the currency goes down the
your earnings go down so I know that the
market basically matches to that so we
know that miners or we estimate that
miners are pretty much breaking even
some are actually running at a slight
loss there's they're good reasons to be
creating bitcoins at a loss for example
if you're in China and you want to
convert your money into something that
you can
then send across borders very easily one
way to do it is not convert it into
dollars and smuggle it but rather to buy
a lot of basically hardware mined
bitcoins out of that and then send the
bitcoins abroad so if you're willing to
do that at the last Rite that's why we
see a lot of Bitcoin mines in in China
and the heaviest miners are really
located there so so it's very hard to
say if if this if this weight is really
increasing but it depends on the cost of
electricity where you're mining and so
on but there are other incentives at
play here but definitely the hash weight
is gone up and I think the most
significant thing is that now if you
want to compete with any serious Bitcoin
miner you have to invest in specialized
Hardware this is this is a sunk cost to
you if you somehow break the system if
you attack it
you don't just win the coins that you
cheated you also lose expected earnings
that you could have gotten from your
special hardware that is now useless for
any other purposes there's nothing you
can do with it okay it's dedicated for
bitcoins all right
so one more thing that I want to show
you is that the use of the currency has
been very very slowly growing so you
might have seen it in the news the the
price of bitcoins goes up and down there
been maybe four bubbles up till now but
in terms of how many messages are sent
to the Bitcoin network people requesting
to move funds this is basically the
number of messages just doesn't say
anything about the amounts or the amount
of money being transferred but basically
we've we've reached around 150 thousand
transactions per day and it's been
slowly growing since you know the very
the very start of Bitcoin and I'm what
I'm going to like to show you is that
this really causes trouble for the
protocol if it keeps you know if we keep
growing you know this is what bitcoin is
intended to do you know we want to
process more transactions but the
protocol is is starting to slowly reach
a point where it might be in danger okay
so this was the introduction to Bitcoin
and now I I want to try and get to to
some of the more interesting results
about incentives and how we've been
looking at them so one of the earlier
works
that that was part of with a machete buy
of shahe Dobbs in ski Sigala Orin was
first to realize that that a lot of
things in in the Bitcoin system are not
incentivized correctly but there's a one
of the first things to notice is that
when you want all the nodes to act as a
bank you have to get the transaction
requests propagated to everyone so that
everyone can can approve transactions
and everybody can compete for the fees
right this this is a very important part
of the vehicle mechanism if you want
competition you have to have them all on
equal footing so Bitcoin includes
basically an underlying layer that
distributes transactions and blocks to
everyone and really nodes don't have an
incentive to send transactions and
blocks to their competitors right why
would I ever do that so we suggested a
few fixes but we're still not really
satisfied with the results because
because these if we implement them will
take up too much space on blocks and
they're still not practical enough for
us to really push for them to be put
into Bitcoin another thing that was very
quickly noticed is that the Bitcoin
protocol itself is not incentive
compatible I mean we're we're giving out
money to people as part of block
creation the question that you might ask
is what would I do to get more money I
mean is the is following the protocol a
good idea or should i do v8 and there's
a wonderful paper by a tile in amine
goons here from Cornell who noticed that
there is a strategy that allows you to
gain more by not following the protocol
so basically what they notice is this
let's say I'm the attacker and I build a
block one of the blocks in as usual but
instead of sending it out I just keep it
I withhold it to myself for use in at a
later time maybe now this could be very
bad for me if if the honest network
builds another block and maybe a second
one before I do anything else I'm going
to basically lose that block right if I
transmit it now to the network it's not
part of the longer chain this is the
longer chain
nobody will adopt it and I've lost a lot
of money that I could have made okay if
I'm off the chain I'm not getting paid
on the other hand what could happen is
that I build another block before you
know that event happens now I'm in a
very good situation if the network
builds another block I can release my
chain and basically destroy what they've
built okay I can get them to lose money
so why do I care about knocking out the
competition if I also lose myself well
really it's one thing to know about the
Bitcoin system is that it it has an
automatic mechanism for for throttling
the speed right for changing the speed
of block creation so that we create
blocks every ten minutes in expectation
so if even if you add more computational
power to the network you are basically
solving these mathematical puzzles much
much in much right much faster but the
difficulty of the problem is
automatically raised so that you you're
not doing it too often to do it only
once every ten minutes so in this case
when we're knocking each other's blocks
out the mechanism would automatically
speed up so that is just as many blocks
are on the chain as should have been if
we were creating them you know every ten
minutes and so the end result is really
that like that I really care about is
what fraction of the blocks on the chain
are mine and what fraction belongs to
the opponent right so if I managed to
knock out many more blocks for every one
that I lose then in terms of the
fraction of blocks that I'm winning I'm
I'm getting ahead okay so that was the
realization of the Alan's here and
really what you should see here is that
if I have been two blocks right of
course the next block that will be built
by the honest- will will definitely fall
but there's also a chance that I've
built a third block or a fourth block
before they do anything and then I
managed to knock out more blocks of
theirs at the same time simultaneously
so this is a very clever non-intuitive
result that that shows that the attacker
can destroy more block than he loses and
and gain as a result luckily for us
perhaps this attack only works if the
attacker has enough computational power
he has to be
large or he needs to communicate very
quickly okay so if you have an attacker
with over one-third of the computational
power in the network they can do this
attack successfully if they can compute
I'm sorry if you that can communicate
fast and send their blocks really faster
than than the blocks of the honest
Network then somehow they can do it with
far less computational power so we
became really interested in this result
mainly because we wanted to solve it for
reasons that I'll also go into a bit
later and the question is how to fix
this what do we do so most of the things
in the protocol are signed
cryptographically I mean when I move
funds I have to have to sign them so the
digital signatures have to check out if
the block is somehow containing things
that are weird
everything that's thrown out every
everything that I write here as an arrow
is really a cryptographic hash so it's
secure if I change a single bits in one
of these blocks the hash will no longer
match so this is all built on tamper
proof data structures and and and so and
this is of course a very important part
that I don't have time to go into but
this is all very very cleverly built
data structure here so we're interested
in fixing the selfish mining problem
anyway but but maybe the first step to
fixing it is to understand how do we
know if we have the right solution right
so what we need to do is to be able to
compute the best response to protocols
in the Bitcoin space so the thing to
know about a I'll serials result is that
it doesn't show the best response it
doesn't show the optimal deviation it
shows you some deviation that works it's
a better response and some people have
made the mistake of thinking that when
they fix the protocol to to cope with
the Allen serials
strategies the specific one that they
gave they actually fixed the protocol
and this is wrong because the attacker
of course will adjust whatever changes
you make in the protocol so really it
boils down to
what to do when you see a sound
situation where the attacker has some
side branch the honest Network has a
certain amount of blocks do we adopt
what the honest Network has done in
throw out our our our effort thus far do
we keep working do we release blocks do
we withhold them so basically we have to
have decisions so we started to look at
this problem and try to think about
utility so like I told you before what
we're really interested in is the
fraction of blocks that we built out of
the total so if we have some policy PI
to handle how we behave then RT of 1
here is the number of blocks that we've
entered into a chain and we're looking
at the fraction of that out of the total
and we're looking at some sort of a non
discounted the infinite problem and if
you're worried about the expectation in
the limit here they can actually prove
that they can be interchanged here in
this problem so we have this weird
reward into our problem but everything
else looks a little bit like an MDP in
the sense that we have a state we know
how many blocks are here and how many
blocks are here that's just a
two-dimensional state and we have
actions that we can take at any point in
time basically we can keep building a
block and on our secret branch we can
throw this out and start working on on
the main chain or we can maybe try and
and release blocks and overrun whatever
the network is done so it turns out and
this is very nice that we can still even
though it's not exactly an MVP we can
reduce this to a problem where we solve
MVPs in sequence yeah so this is I'm not
looking at it as a game I'm thinking of
the network as all composed of honest
players right I'm trying to see if I'm
if I can deviate from this equilibrium
right so the network is basically honest
its publishing everything it does
everything nicely and it's of course
very interesting to think of what
happens when we have a game but we're
interested in even a simpler question do
we have a protocol that is incentive
compatible so is it
equilibrium right it's even simpler so
we know how to reduce this to MVPs and
what we get out of this is is these
policies that basically do optimal
selfish mining in in Bitcoin and and the
way to read this of course is is this is
the length of the chain by the honest
network this is the length of the
attackers chain and here you just have
your action of what to do so if I have a
chain of length four and the other
network has a chain of length two I will
wait which means basically keep building
my secret branch override here basically
means that this is off this secondary
kind of the secondary diagonal here
basically says I will send my blocks out
and I gain as a result I destroy some of
the blocks of the honest network and
adopt means that I give up my chance I'm
too far behind there's no way that I'll
profits if I continue so you might
notice here a very curious thing
sometimes it's worth to still work worth
it to still work on a problem even if
I'm behind like if I am the attacker and
I have four blocks and the network has
maybe even six I can still keep working
and gain as a result this is kind of
surprising and this is something a
feature that the Alan Sears strategy did
not have partial I so every time I do
override I really this is a partial
release in the sense that I release just
one block more than the note then the
onus network it happens to be here on
the diagonal so all I have is one block
more because if I have two blocks more I
can just wait until the network builds
another block and I release then I do
more damage there's really no reason to
release everything too early so we've
thought about all of these situations
yeah
however I have in my network yes yes so
we actually have to know basically run
this solver for whatever value of
computational power that you the
attacker has and there's also another
parameter that I didn't talk about which
which kind of captures the the the speed
at which the attacker communicates and
actually when you look at speeds that
are better than zero which is what I
wrote here the state space that you need
actually has more more bits to it that
I'm not talking about here so this is
our basic result and this is a paper
that's up on archive so you can all have
a look at what what we do there and in
part of the results as well so some of
the results of course are that smaller
miners then the islands here I really
thought can can profit from the Bitcoin
attacks but we still but now we can say
that this is really the the optimal
attack so we do have bounds we can
really say that you have to be bigger
than some some fraction in order to gain
we've we've done analysis of several
fixes that were proposed a allen sir had
a fix that they proposed in their paper
we show that it's slightly worse that
they thought you can adjust your
strategy to it and there were other
papers that have basically suggested
fixes to selfish mining work that we
basically show that have done much more
damage than good
basically they remove this bound on on
the size of the attacker altogether so
another piece of really bad news that
comes out of our paper is that in
networks with delays where we start to
think of messages taking time to
propagate through the network selfish
mining becomes profitable for all miners
of all sizes okay so this is just a
second this is something that we care
about mostly because when blocks start
to grow when we try to send more
transactions through the Bitcoin network
deviation becomes easier and becomes
more profitable this is a problem yeah
Kevin
so imagine that what you're really
saying is every miner would profit from
unilaterally deviating not everyone
would profit from deviating at the same
time no that's right so all I'm saying
is that protocol itself is not an
equilibrium if you just take the model
of a land sea or air and and you say
everybody is really bad at communicating
we can say something like the protocol
is in equilibrium as long as miners have
a you know are below a certain threshold
of size well the question of what it
does is I think very difficult to do
it's very hard to figure out what
happens when people don't follow the
protocol because basically you have
chains that are hidden from you know
releasing them doesn't even mean that
they're accepted by anyone so that I
think the protocol basically falls apart
and what we really want is not to think
of a new equilibrium we want to
establish the protocol as an equilibrium
that's somehow my intuition of what's
going on if you have a way of finding a
different equilibrium that's also
somewhat good that'll be wonderful but I
doubt that'll be found ok so there are
many more incentive issues that I'm not
going to have time to touch on some of
them are related to the free markets
right Bitcoin starts to stop slowly to
print money and start to rely more and
more on fees so these are very important
so I'm gonna skip this because I want to
use my last five minutes to to talk
about something else and this is a
recent work that we're going to upload
to our traffic again in maybe a week or
two and it's talking about basically
changing the core of the protocol of the
Bitcoin protocol and the reason that I
want to show you this is because I think
there are hidden links here to the
computation of social choice or to
social choice in general and at this
point this is just intuitions I want to
show you these intuitions and how they
help us build better protocols in
Bitcoin ok so what we're trying to do is
get rid of the longest chain rule and
replace it with something better and the
intuitions to how to do this I think
come from social choice so I'll quickly
explain what's wrong with the current
protocol it's very very slow we're
we're currently processing 3.3
transactions per second at maximum if we
if we stress the the protocol visa is
doing maybe 2,000 or more that was in
2010 it was doing two thousand
transactions per second
reportedly so we need to scale up maybe
three orders of magnitude Bitcoin blocks
are also built once every ten minutes we
don't want to wait ten minutes until a
transaction is approved even a little
bit we want faster confirmation times
these two problems are really related
okay so why are they related because
when we try to increase the blocks rate
or the block sizes we start to have
these conflicts basically nodes start to
solve the the the puzzle nearly at the
same time without hearing about each
other's blocks if blocks are really
created quickly before they can
propagate or if we propagate them very
slowly then we start to get more and
more Forks in the network in the in the
blockchain it doesn't look like a change
anymore more like a tree and now what
happens is when an attacker shows up and
he wants to switch our world view he
needs just a very small number of blocks
to do this so in this case three blocks
will displace the longest chains here
even though the network has spent a lot
of computational effort building
basically five blocks here they're only
easily displaced by three so right we
need our protocol to be somehow more
tolerant for delays so it will allow
these Forks to occur but still secure so
how can we do that so I want to show
what what is the intuition of the link
to social choice right so think of the
longest chain protocol it for a moment
facing you know these two chains let's
say there's a transaction here where
somebody wants to buy pasta for some
reason and a different transaction here
not necessarily the set by the same
person who wants to buy pizza
okay so I'll call these pasta and pizza
just because it's easier now when we
build another block on top of this chain
what are we supposed to do right so so
the so the rule basically tells us to
extend a long chain but I want to show
you a different way of thinking about it
let's think of blocks as voters for a
moment we have three blocks that say
yeah
pasta is better than pizza and two
blocks that say pizza is better than
pasta okay so what do we want this block
to do basically we tell them run the
plurality voting rule you you get the
result the result is pasta and vote for
the winner right join the longest chain
means basically join in this case the
majority or the plural plurality so this
is very nice but where does get us I'll
show you in a second another very nice
thing that we can do that comes also
with an inspiration from from mechanism
design right this block shows up and we
have a rule you need to pick the longest
chain so that's one way of thinking
about it but what if we apply the
revelation principle so we tell them
okay don't pick a chain just tell us
everything that you know and we will
push the decision into the into the rule
itself so when I see this block pointing
to these two if I want to follow the
longest chain rule I can say okay this
is obviously the longest chain and I can
forget this link right so this is a
revelation principle in work in let's
work here and I can basically say
something like if if if if I now have
this extra information maybe I have a
larger design space of protocols and
actually what we can do is we can
incorporate the contents of these blocks
now even though they were previously
would have been thrown out by the
longest chain rule we can say that maybe
there are transactions here that don't
conflict with the ones that we have up
there we can still process them there's
no reason not to instead of having to
transmit them again within our block and
also we can tell the difference between
these two scenarios this is now very
different than this this is a block that
may have been delayed but is reported
this is a block that is delayed but may
have not been reported yet so it's it
could be still kept secret by an
attacker so this looks more like an
attack than that one so this is a very
interesting thing that we can leverage
off of and now what we have is instead
of a a chain we're basically
down to a direct acyclic graph let me
push the protocol a bit more
let's not output a chain let's let's do
something else we have a direct acyclic
graph what I suggest is that we output a
linear order over all the blocks instead
of a chain so we call this property
chalice protocols basically what we say
is we want now in an order of all these
blocks think of it it might be a
topological order this is what we end up
with anyway and now how do I think about
the transactions that are processed here
I'll read them from start to finish and
I'll do what the bank did before every
time I see something that doesn't work
with the history I throw it out
so I process transactions in order just
ordering transactions is enough so a
chain is a way to do this but this is a
better way because it includes all the
blocks and now I'm even closer to social
choice I'm outputting orders from my
mechanism right this is this is already
very interesting so here's maybe the
last insight from social choices that I
that I want to show you and this really
gives us a brand new protocol so think
again of pasta and pizza showing up here
and we're in a network with delays where
blocks might show up right and I'm
everything here all the arrows that they
have but but the longest chain would
have picked this one so for you
following the longest chain protocol we
basically have a tie between these two
chains because every one of these blocks
has Caesar ties they might be breaking
ties differently now the question that
we must ask ourselves can we think of
these transactions as secure if they are
secure if we have accepted them then we
need to do so without fear of change you
can remind in the future how secure are
they so of course what we've seen is
that an attacker might might show up
with a slightly longer chain and change
our mind now I want to give you the
social choice analogy for this problem
okay so here's the analogy that that
plays out in my head anyway
so I wanted you to ignore these blocks
as voters for a second just think of the
ones that follow so what I'm going to
claim is that we have
a voting situation where there are these
two guys who really want to have pasta
and their second preference is pizza
okay they they why do they like this
alternative it's because this is a block
that they've seen versus a block that
they haven't write a blog that you
haven't seen might be an attacker the
box that you have is not an attack
because if there was a conflicting
transaction here we would know it
because we saw the block so this is an
attack right and and and we like pasta
over pizza there are two votes here
pizza over pasta these are these two
guys and this is the attacker basically
he likes he wants to change her mind so
he puts burgers in in front of pastas
and pizzas so the thing that we know
from computational social choice is that
the Condor say loser in this case wins
so what is the converse a loser burger
is basically if you compare them burgers
to pasta right these four guys are going
to say we prefer pasta burgers pasta
burger and pass this burger and three
guys are only going to say we prefer
burgers to pasta all right so this is a
choice that loses in all pairwise
elections but gets elected here so this
is a very rough intuition into what's
right these two guys are basically
fighting among themselves and this guy
takes takes the whole prize so the
result that we basically have that we're
going to put up and I'm not going to
formally state it that we have a chains
protocol that fix an order of blocks and
it's resilient in the presence of these
delays to double spending attacks and to
confirmation delay attacks it's based on
voting with rank pairs which just
doesn't pick the controversy loser
that's that's the basis of the approach
and really blocks have preferences where
they prefer the things that they saw
over the things that they didn't so this
is the intuition that led us I cannot
really draw the really clear line
between computational social choice and
and and these protocols but all these
intuitions have really guided us forward
when we were working on this and I think
there is something deeper there and
unfortunately the protocol is actually
more complicated than that
I've described here their votes going
from the past to the future future to
the past it's very hard to do so I have
no time to show it I'm actually past my
time I might okay so I'll conclude this
is an Israeli shekel this is you know
regular money it's very simple you know
I give you a coin you have one I don't
this is really complicated so it's a
system with a lot of moving parts we can
attack it in many many different places
in some sense bitcoin already exceeds
expectations I mean the system this
complex could not have been standing
this long it should not have been right
and it's not surprise that we find a lot
of these issues with it so we still need
a bunch more work on incentives and I
I'm really optimistic I think it can be
done I think the system can be made to
work and there are maybe are more deeper
connections between watt of genuine
social choice that we're still working
on figuring out all right I'll stop here
thank you
so so basically what the protocol tries
to do at the moment is if if you if your
block is outside of the main chain you
don't get paid for it
so one way to think about it is this is
a penalty for attackers if you try to do
this attack and you failed and you
usually will fail then you've lost the
money but really when you think of the
selfish mining result that the islands
here have shown it really shows that you
can keep blocks to yourself maybe
potentially build long chains as you do
this you are still profitable in
expectation you can still launch attacks
so solving the selfish mining problem
also will help a lot in solving in
making attackers pay for double spending
in some sense so there is an attempt to
do it it just didn't work out so at the
moment we haven't been looking at
selfish mining every every protocol
that's ever been suggested you know to
replace Bitcoin has had its own selfish
mining issues we're just hoping that
once we move to this direct revelation
sort of thing basically what we're
looking for is truthfulness now you just
have to report all of the links that you
have and one more thing that we need is
that you don't delay block your the
release of your blocks so it might be
that there's no protocol and we have
indications that it's it's hard to set
up the incentives it could happen but
we'll be satisfied with just getting a
bound I mean if all miners are below
certain size and and we are immune to
surface mining that would also be good
for us
right right so people have been looking
I have been doing this monitoring of the
network to see if the selfish mining
attack is occurring and what they've
looked at is exactly the statistics of
inter arrival times of blocks the
problem is that once you try to look at
at your own clock in in in a distributed
protocol that already gives you problems
because clocks are not synchronized
you're subject to all sorts of attacks
by doing that it's I'm not saying but
but but it could be a good idea to look
at the local clock and just try and
measure time between different blocks
but this could also be used by attackers
in right so everything that you do is
very sensitive and especially when you
when you're looking at clocks in in the
protocol
hey thanks again thank you